the newest Democrat running for
president says he has a proven record of
beating Republicans and working with
them his name is Steve Bullock he's
Montana's governor and he's a 23rd
candidate to enter the race for the
Democratic nomination he launched his
campaign yesterday in a high school
science classroom where he was once a
student Bullock sat down with ed O'Keefe
for his first TV interview as a
candidate that is in Helena Montana with
his conversation with the governor Edie
good morning to you good morning Gail
governor Bullock waited so long to jump
in because he had to finish his day job
the state legislature dropped three
hundred bills on his desk last week that
he either had to sign or veto and he
says it's that executive experience that
justifies him joining an already crowded
field I'm the only one that actually
wanted a trump State I was on the ballot
when Trump got elected he took Montana
by 20 I won by 4 Montana Governor Steve
Bullock says his ability to reach across
the aisle sets him apart from his
Democratic opponents I've also been able
to really bridge divides here I mean my
legislators always been at least 60% of
Republican in a field of 23 contenders
it'll be an uphill battle for Bullock to
break through in order to qualify for
the first Democratic presidential debate
just over a month away he'll have to
register at least one percent support in
three separate polls or find 65,000
unique campaign donors across at least
20 states Bullock says he wants to
defeat President Trump to make sure
every American has a fair shot at being
successful do you think President Trump
is a good role model no I don't why not
the way that he conducts in the office
and divides people
how he belittled people that's not the
example that you want out of a president
I mean when we're expecting more of our
preschoolers at times than a president
that that's not the role model that I
think most families want for their kids
a majority of Democrats support
impeaching the president a majority of
Americans don't do you support it do you
support impeaching President Trump I
support Congress doing full
investigations as they should that's
their job and people are more worried
about am I gonna be able for college is
my kid gonna get sick Moloch is also the
former Montana Attorney General and says
tackling campaign finance reform is one
of his signature issues he also wants
universal background checks for gun
purchases and to address climate change
the governor told us China is a major
economic threat but that new tariffs are
hurting Americans tariffs to fit your
stay pretty hard especially the wheat
farmers I know and there have been
millions given to them in relief but is
that the way to combat no
a payment from the Department of
Agriculture isn't gonna make up for the
market's loss this would be long-term
injury along the way for our producers
not just here but all across this
country who's our greatest global phone
I think our greatest global full foe
potentially is ourselves if we continue
to have the level divisive nough sui
have really yeah when the rest of the
world sees that Congress and the
president can't agree or the divisive
'no so we've seen on every single
potential the military action or other
so potentially we are our own worst
enemy well I think we can be we also
asked governor Bullock whether he'd pick
one of the six women running for
president as his running mate if he's
ever the nominee he said that while they
are
while there are incredibly talented
women in the field ultimately he's
looking for the most qualified person
whether that's a man or a woman
Nora really interesting it I don't think
I've ever heard a candidate running for
president described America as
potentially America's great
Global foul interesting remark thank you